I'm always critical and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
penguin zero moist critical Charlie big
moist huge Charles
what is moist critical a five foot six
Hawking testosterone Titan who makes a
bunch of wacky silly garbage on the
internet what does moist critical do for
a living I just post really ridiculous
things on the internet and got lucky
enough that it enables me to survive
what did moist critical do before
YouTube nothing I was I was 10 before
YouTube I didn't have a career or a job
I was still just snorting glue and
drinking milk I was just a baby boy I
used to mow Lawns for money which
probably isn't allowed with the child
labor laws in America what is moist
critical email just criticalcontact at
gmail you're gonna have a hard time
reaching me there I did meet one of my
best friends through email his name's
Kaya he reached out a long time ago with
a super sad message that really tickled
my heartstrings I replied back we became
good friends through it but these days
most people just sign me up for cult
newsletters and a lot of other like
really awful WebMD like hypochondriac
bait but you're welcome to send me
something I probably won't see it though
I'll just give it one of these
why is moist critical
penguin zero the lore is super simple I
was actually a child I made the account
in 2007 I was 11. I thought Penguins
were cool the name penguin was taken not
that deep why does moist critical wear
white shirts convenience most of
everything I have in my life comes from
Walmart so I just get big packs of white
shirts and that's good enough for me I'm
not out here trying to make any kind of
fashion statements so it's super simple
super easy why does moist critical
talk like that that's a question for God
not me I couldn't tell you it's just I
have very weird vocal cords I have a
very monotone voice the best description
I've heard of it is that it sounds like
an unenthusiastic hand job I've been
really gravitating towards the word
goofy over the last year or so I like
these words that kind of fell out of
Grace for a while old expressions like
calling someone an old battle ax or a
harpy or a harlot goofy silly wacky it's
like fetal development where you're in
like the zygotic stage all the way till
birth right now I'm in like the goofy
development why does moist critical
look like Jesus I just don't think I do
I I really don't I just have long hair
and I'm short I don't know if Jesus was
short but other than that I think that's
where the similarity stop you had like
really brown hair mine's more black I
don't think I look like him at all but
most people seem to think I do
is moist critical in a band yeah it's a
two-man band it's me and my buddy Troy
he's from New Zealand We Are The Gentle
men Troy does all of the music I do all
the lyrics and vocals that's why a lot
of them are very silly like 2019 guy is
all about being a cuck and being super
happy about it and skynet's all about
robots that are powered by human semen
from the future he does all the really
good music stuff and I do all the super
stupid stuff we make a great team is
moist critical
from Florida I was born in Tampa moved
to Orlando moved back to Tampa in sixth
grade and I've been here ever since I'm
not leaving until Florida is fully
underwater and even then I might still
stick around I don't think I have very
many Florida man qualities other than
maybe the way I dress or where I go I
guess we went to a club called The
Castle last week which is a goth
nightclub with a station for paddling
and all kinds of like bunk beds but I
don't think I have many Florida man
qualities myself
not that I can think of at least is
moist critical
jacked not to toot my own horn but I do
lift very often I was a human science
major with a concentration in exercise
physiologies but I'm not really jacked I
keep myself lean because I'm five foot
six so if I get jacked I look like a
meatball and it looks really gross is
moist critical
scared of cockroaches nope common
misconception I scream because I'm
trying to scare them away so I'm not
afraid of anything except flying this
moist critical scared of flying what do
you know yeah I am scared of flying it's
my main phobia really the only phobia
does critical
have a world record not anymore every
time I get a world record I post about
it and some Goblin out there goes and
takes it from me most of my previous
records were Speed Run related so gaming
Mr Krabs overdoses on ketamine and dies
it got taken I held a record in House of
Caravan got taken I did have a record
for a little while kind of not an
official one for sex toy collecting but
then Bell belfine beat me so right now
no world records and probably never will
hold one for long but I have had
previous records when did critical
reveal his face
2015 I think I started posting on
Snapchat and doing like recorder covers
of popular music and then I eventually
posted that Snapchat in a comment on a
video called paint the town red and I
don't think I started putting it in
videos until 2016 or 2017. does critical
have Discord
I don't go on it super often only to
talk to like friends or do voice calls
with friends but I do have it
foreign
that was outrageous sorry about that
what is penguin Zero's favorite anime
Code Geass it is I think a masterpiece
it has one of my favorite endings in all
of fiction and I think the whole thing
is just beautifully written what this
penguin zero drive an SUV I got an SUV a
little over a year ago I just like the
SUV more because I'm very risk averse so
it's a safer vehicle what is penguin
zero favorite game City of Heroes it's
an old MMO that I think is truly
underrated shutdown in 2012 God rested
soul but I think it's still an
incredible game there's private servers
I still play from time to time I guess
second to City of Heroes would be Halo
2.
does Charles Christopher White Jr have a
brother not that I know of I'm pretty
sure I'm the only child but I've never
really sat my parents down to get to the
bottom of it I'm pretty sure it's just
me this Charles Christopher White Jr act
in Hunger Games don't ask silly
questions you know the answer yes I'm
the only thing that held that entire
franchise together and it's an absolute
shame that they didn't call me back for
the most recent one I'm very
disappointed with their decision but I
will never forget the time I spent on
that set is Charles Christopher White Jr
still alive
can moist critical play guitar I tried I
played in middle school I dropped it in
high school I haven't really touched it
since I can do uh Tears Don't Fall intro
still I think but other than that
nothing else how did moist critical
get famous I didn't you've been misled I
just post on the internet and some
people watch it and that's really about
it but I guess maybe the Hunger Games
would be the another answer to that when
does moist critical stream pretty much
every night times vary all very
spontaneous sometimes I don't stream
every day you never really know you
gotta stay on your toes does moist
critical
use a script nope fire on the camera
talk about absolute nonsense and that's
about the extent of the effort that goes
into that unless we're doing something
like wrestling with wrestling we plan
out a lot of what goes on beforehand but
when it's just a normal video it's super
simple I just start talking about some
really goofy and that's about it
thanks for having me on a big you
to the Hunger Games for not bringing me
back District 8 Hospital helper is the
only glue that held that disheveled
franchise together aside from that it
was just a lot of fun thank you for
putting it together